it's a beautiful beautiful horse
temperament 5 out of 10. did they put
that on the ad the 5 out of 10 and
what's that rating scale on
what's going on gq it's post malone and
today i'm going on a shopping spree
[Music]
let's check out some accessories
givenchy
blackhorn cap 1085
bucks paneled cotton canvas cap in black
say that three times fast cotton canvas
got cotton canvas cap that's hard horn
appliques
that crown
i think they sent me one of these but it
was red i really appreciate a good
applique
oakley shield sunglasses
790 bucks shield style acetate frame
sunglasses in black tonal rubberized
trim throughout single mirrored lens and
silver tone with a hundred percent uv
protection where's the cutoff of uv
protection to where you just can't see i
think they look sick these are sick
clint orms hidalgo 1800 bronc rider
trophy buckle 17
110
sterling silver center dome i'm a sucker
for a sterling silver center dome
features a 14 karat yellow gold bronc
rider on the center dome made and
engraved by hand in texas by clint orms
engravers and silversmiths
this is a fantastic belt buckle i'd
prefer a rectangular belt buckle but the
silver center dome is just incredible
i'm always
in a belt buckle need you can never have
too many a lot of the work like i
remember i went to cheyenne
and they were doing the rodeo there and
i got a belt buckle from there and
that's like the coolest thing ever and
i'm like scared to wear it because i'm
just terrible with belts because i'll
just get they're always too tight
because i'm a little tubby
and so i take them off and i'll like
tuck it over in the corner somewhere and
i'm terrible at losing them so i'm
scared to wear it fish slippers
21.99 that's a lot of money i actually
own these i didn't know they were that
much
yeah i do
of course
i think it's got to be the shield
sunglasses i think those are the coolest
things yeah i got the hat and red thank
you giovanni that's very sweet and and
pretty [ __ ] and thing the fish slippers
maybe i'll wear them all together though
i have the fish slippers i have the hat
i got the sunglasses i have belt buckles
not like clint orms though but yeah if
that was more rectangular it'd have to
be the clean worms
[Music]
let's check out some vintage memorabilia
what this is cool this is cool dave
mustaine's personally owned number one
mega death sign guitar
32
304. this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity to own the personal tour use
custom v guitar of legendary platinum
selling grammy-winning guitar god dave
mustain of mega death this thing is so
cool
dave mustain is like the sweetest dude
and he can really get down i think this
is a reasonable price i don't know how
you play a flying v because usually i
play guitar uh couched
i don't know how you play a flying v
couch you have to kind of do like this
cool pose that i'm not cool enough to do
so you like put it like in between then
you're like
it doesn't work but i guess like
standing up it makes sense because he
plays it standing up and he really plays
it he's just also a good guitar player
which i am not
[Music]
1996 dallas cowboys signed helmet
six thousand two hundred and twenty
seven dollars also a very specific
number
super bowl champs team signed game model
helmet
with a beckett letter of offense his
city
words are hard i wonder if it's signed
by the entire team if so i think that's
pretty neat it's a model helmet if only
if it was like one of like the
the real deal helmets that would be
pretty pretty epic this is a beta
edition black lotus 42 000 look at that
nice round number that's an easy number
there's no
49s or 62s it's three mana of any single
color of your choice to your mana pool
then is discarded tapping this artifact
can be played as an interrupt i think
it's a good price for this i mean this
is the most busted card
in magic the gathering i'm not a nerd i
wouldn't know
i just built a no band a no-ban deck
list for commander with leovolt and i
put one of these in there and all the
mocks in there and i'm so pumped and i
can't wait to piss my friends off i have
one of these it's an artist proof signed
by chris rush and it's really it's super
it's super sick so you got alpha beta
and then unlimited but like the alpha
ones are super rounded so you can always
tell if it's an alpha card
oh yeah the betas are usually it's just
so hard because there's not so many
alphas especially black lotus like in
good condition so a lot of them are like
super slabs and then they're worth a lot
of money i was in the bidding for one of
these ones for like 550 000 for an alpha
one it was nine five the cowboys helmet
is awesome i got a lot of boys on the
team now and my house has too much
cowboy stuff in it already it's gotta be
the uh but see you know how can a magic
card be more than the mega death guitar
i get it i get it completely i spent too
much money on those things i'll do the
dave mustaine guitar sorry lotus i gotta
go with my gut
[Music]
let's check out some sweet rides
1968
ford bronco 65 000.
custom bumpers tow winch spotlights bar
lights
upgraded the starter
i know what that means
lift kit new paint and it also comes
with a bikini top i think this car is
super badass i'm actually i'm building a
bronco right now i love the old like the
new broncos they did a good job with but
the old ones like 68 you know like the
70s like they're just so so pretty
dolan tandem track bike 1915
the dolan tdt tandem track bite is cut
for speed this is so cool and i love the
term in tandem this does definitely look
it's built for speed cut for speed this
is um
exactly what you want if you want to
ride a bike with your boy um
or
your wife or anybody you know do they
have one of those drinking bikes
wherever you sit
in like the square and drink and
everybody's just pedaling do they have
any of those built for speed
because that's something i'm very
interested in
white on delaysian stallion did i say
that right on delusion stallion sixteen
thousand dollars height
seventeen what's hh weight in pounds
1400 temperament 5 out of 10.
it's a beautiful beautiful horse did
they put that on the ad the 5 out of 10
and what's that rating scale on because
i don't know what hh is 17
oh hand that's how you measure horses oh
whose hands though whose hands shack's
hands because they're so that's a huge
horse temperament what's the temperament
rating on five kilojoules out of ten in
the temperament i think that's a
beautiful horse i don't know i have to
meet it meet them and
see what that five out of ten is
actually about private jet 2019 cessna
citation that's a badass name for a jet
because if you get a citation in
a private jet that's like probably the
coolest [ __ ] thing of all time 9.8
million dollars
immaculate no damage history featuring
the extremely rare to find lightning
fast 4.8 hardware and software upgrades
i don't really like airplanes this is
cool if you get a ticket in your private
jet that's probably one of the coolest
things of all time but um
yeah i'm scared of flying the horse is
beautiful temperament five out of ten
i'm not sure though definitely not the
plane i am too tubby to ride the bike
i'm gonna have to go with the thing that
is gonna be most practical for me that's
gonna be the 1968 bronco
oh yeah oh sorry
[Music]
show me some real estate
lights castle estonia
two million dollars six hundred and
ninety six thousand one hundred and
fifty six dollars the property presents
16 bedrooms an exquisite courtyard state
of the art conference rooms a stunning
roof terrace with a bar and a large
sauna facility i have done one show in
estonia and it is so beautiful we ran
around and we went to this haunted place
and started looking around we had a
great time but this house is crazy 16
bedrooms i like having a bunch of space
to run around because i have a lot of
[ __ ] blackout curtains that's the most
important thing if the house doesn't
have them i'll put them in but that's
like the most important thing that's my
biggest creature comfort because
i'm not very good at waking up at with
the sun
it drives me nuts and i get hot 16
bedrooms it sounds really nice
i'm not looking for 16 but if it has 16
i think that's pretty cool
doheny road beverly hills california
15 million
995
000
luxury and tranquility meet
in this captivating reimagined single
story sanctuary whoa
the alliteration and the tongue twisters
oh single story sanctuary situated
behind private gardens on a sprawling
over half
half acre
half acre
lush flat lot in one of beverly hills
most exclusive enclaves masterfully
reconstructed with an open and balanced
modern design four bedrooms four
bathrooms that's insane i can't believe
they said over half acre it's nice i you
know i feel the same because i i'm
staying in la for a little minute now
and the spot's actually huge like and i
was so surprised but in l.a you get such
little tiny spots so like half acre
they're like this is [ __ ] insane like
what do we do with all this space
there's so much room for activities and
stuff but
i don't know i think it's pretty i just
think a lot of those four bedrooms as in
estonia you get 16 bedrooms 16 million
bucks
bailey colorado 11 million 500 000
deer creek valley ranch and its majestic
165 acres of idyllic colorado living is
the ultimate mountain getaway with the
convenience of being less than an hour
from denver
this one-of-a-kind property boasts
outstanding mountain views sweeping
meadows abundant wildlife riding trails
and deer creek flowing year round with
extensive water rights included eight
bedrooms and a five plus car garage my
girl would absolutely hate it but it's
awesome she i i was trying to i was
looking at all these houses and there's
so much like property in like wyoming
and stuff but
they're all like super log cabiny and
she hates it i'm like oh this is cool
this is badass you got saddles on the
seat that's cool like she would like the
dohini house yeah but not that i like
this one but she doesn't like this look
but this is gorgeous and you get the
water rights i think this is very nice
rhinebeck new york eight million nine
hundred and thirty one thousand and
sixteen dollars five thousand square
feet of living space on forty acres of
land fully furnished built in 2020 it
combines top of the line design finishes
modern technology with a warm country
vibe
five bedrooms four bathrooms
this is really nice
rhinebeck is very pretty
this is very pretty a little bit more
modern for for her we're both buying
this it's not just me but how many lake
acres did it say 40 acres
that's a lot of money
ah estonian castle in a heartbeat i
think i think that's the move here i
would love that the castle of lights
i wonder how old it is
does it say how old it is
oh that's definitely haunted we're gonna
do this one i like this one yeah this is
the winner here
[Music]
thanks everybody for watching me spend
this money i'll see you next time